saving somebody's life is the most
heroic thing you can do right but in
this video we will see how a police
officer even made this heroic need
something that the person involved in
Saving a shooting victim would regret
his whole life on October 9th 2020 a
retired firefighter Joseph Garces was
driving his Jeep in Santa Paula
California when he noticed a man named
Samir Salgado lying in a parking lot
covered in a liquid upon approaching
Salgado Garces realized that the liquid
was blood and that the man had been shot
in the face the man was armed with both
a gun and a knife tucked into his
waistband Garces quickly seized the gun
unloaded it and carefully placed it on
the floorboard of his Jeep then he
retrieved the knife using it to
carefully cut open the man's shirt
before immediately starting to
administer CPR but little did Garces
know that this act of kindness would
cost him deeply soon after he started
administering CPR several police
officers and paramedics from the Santa
Paula Police Department arrived on the
scene and took charge of the CPR instead
of appreciating Mr Garces for trying to
save a life they made things worse for
him
stay over here stay over here stay over
here come over here
that's your car that's my car I was
driving by I thought Garces told the
officers that he was just passing by
when he saw the victim and that he was
only there to help he also told the cops
that Salgado wasn't breathing and that
he didn't detect the pulse so his
training kicked in and he started
performing CPR but there wasn't much
maturity in the police officer's way of
handling the situation they started
investigating Garces like he was one of
the shooters okay not a part of this we
don't know anything about that we'll see
I got in the car you're not going there
do you have your idea it's in the car
what's your name Jill Garces as the
first responding officers continued
interviewing Garces another officer
Detective Chris Rivera arrived on the
scene who without even taking into
account what had happened asked other
officers to get this guy out of here
Garces who was already tired of the
cop's non-stop question didn't like
Rivera's attitude at all
he's a witness
relax relax
okay if you're a good detective you
wouldn't be yelling at me right now
you'd be taking care of your job after
getting a strong reply from Garces it
was clear that detective Rivera's ego
had been hurt get out of my crime scene
he started yelling at Garces
I'm gonna make you next time get out of
my crime scene come with me
knowing that detective Rivera was
looking for a reason to arrest him
Garces complied with his lawful but rude
requirement and left the crime scene but
even then Rivera wasn't happy and
continued yelling darcis reminded him
and other responding police officers
that he had worked with the Santa Paula
PD for 27 years while being a
firefighter but there was no change in
Rivera's attitude who continued
screaming at Garces even though he had
left his crime scene
I wonder if people will give you guys
the benefit of the doubt and I work with
you for 27 years why do I get my car
back then hey tell them thank you for
teaching me not to be helpful you fat
peace yeah Garces told the officers that
their arrogance was the main reason why
many citizens have begun to treat them
with less respect however instead of
taking this feedback coming from a
retired firefighter as something to work
with detector Rivera took it personally
and his pay gave up Rivera left the
crime scene and ran toward Garces
thank you
upon approaching Garces detector Rivera
forcibly put his hands on Garces
shoulders and c-clamped his forearm and
elbow now this was a totally bad move on
the detective's part in order for an
officer's use of force against the
citizen to be constitutional it must be
reasonable under the Fourth Amendment
you see the fourth amendment gives
citizens the right to be secure in their
person against unreasonable seizures
since there was no violence from
Garcia's side detective Rivera grabbing
him in that manner was completely
unreasonable in addition to that
whenever detaining or arresting a
citizen police officers shall inform the
citizen that he is being detained or
arrested as we can see without giving a
single warning to him detective Rivera
violently grabbed Garces and forced him
against a tree but the Constitution
wasn't the only thing that detective
Rivera violated while arresting Garces
he also breached the policy of the Santa
Paula Police Department according to the
sppd use of force policy officers shall
use only that amount of force that
reasonably appears necessary even the
fact and totality of the circumstances
known to or perceived by the officer
himself
[Music]
turn around
Rivera handcuffed Garces put him under
arrest
however realizing that he would only
make things worse he gave the custody of
Garces to another officer who was way
more well-behaved and reasonable than
him just so you know I'm retired because
of PTSD major anxiety problems
in handcuffs
gotta do it keep away from me got him he
is accelerating this way more than I am
I won't let him talk to him you want the
windows down or anything the officer
informed Garces that he was being
detained despite him being handcuffed
but even in order to detain a citizen
the officers need to have a reasonably
articulated suspicion that the citizen
has committed is committing or is about
to commit a crime which was clearly
missing in the case of Garces sure
Garces was yelling arguing with the
detective but this doesn't mean that he
was doing anything illegal narcissus had
even left the crime scene on the demand
of the officer and his actions became
reasonable when you consider detective
Rivera's attitude and actions it was
continuously criticizing Garces even
according to the First Amendment Garces
right to speech is protected even if it
is intended to interfere with the
performance of an officer's Duty which
was clearly not the case as Rivera had
all the Liberty to work on the case and
not get involved in an argument with
Garces it seems that either detective
Rivera didn't know anything about Garces
rights or if he did know he didn't pay
much respect to him and proceeded to
violate them the officers held Garces in
the back of a police car for 15 minutes
before detective Rivera took off the
handcuffs and informed him that he was
free to go however the damage had
already been done Garces told the
officers that he wasn't feeling well and
then he needed to see a doctor shortly
after an ambulance was called to the
scene and Garces was transported to
Community Memorial Hospital where he
received treatment for a dislocated
shoulder and torn labrum which was
surgically repaired while Garces was
undergoing surgery the shooting victim
that he had helped earlier by performing
CPR Samir Salgado was also getting
better in the hospital fortunately he
survived the shooting and his victimizer
of 42 year old Santa Paula resident
Richard Valencia was arrested and
charged with attempted murder shortly
after the case is still pending in court
to this day after fully recovering from
the injuries Joseph Garces came forward
to hold Rivera accountable for the
violation of his rights on August 19
2021 Garces filed a federal lawsuit
against detective Rivera in the city of
Santa Paula claiming that his civil
rights had been violated the lawsuit
also contained a federal claim regarding
the excessive use of force but to
Garcia's surprise in the hearing of
March 24 4th 2023 U.S District Judge
Fernando L Anita Rocha ruled that Rivera
had qualified immunity and couldn't be
held liable for the federal excessive
force because judge Fernando didn't
consider a sea clamp as a violation of
the Fourth Amendment the case will not
proceed against the city of Santa Paula
but not Rivera the city's expert former
Pasadena Police Chief Philip Sanchez
testified that Rivera did nothing wrong
but there are also some people who sided
with Garces I kind of feel for this guy
the sfsu professor Jeffrey snipe said
referring to Garces he stops he renders
Aid everything is cool calm and
collected until this officer shows up he
probably saves this guy's life every
single step he takes is appropriate he
takes the gun takes the bullets out
removes the knife and then Rivera gets
on the scene and upends the whole thing
we saw in the moment detective Rivera
arrived on the scene he started talking
down on Garces who was doing nothing
wrong but helping the victim Rivera
yelled at Garces and asked his
subordinates to get Garces out of the
spot it was clear that Rivera didn't
want anybody to do what he believed was
his duty while Garces was providing a
witness statement Rivera lashed out at
him without thinking for a second that
this man had saved the life of a
shooting victim moments ago as if that
wasn't enough after kicking Garces out
of the crime scene Rivera followed him
to the other side and then proceeded to
use excessive force against him Rivera's
actions look even worse when you
consider that he had received training
for de-escalating the situation and not
escalating it which is exactly what he
did Rivera let his ego take over the
situation and made matters worse if the
police are to have a respectful
relationship with citizens and if they
want to cooperate with other professions
they have to respect other humans and
their contribution to society just like
other citizens are to respect their
profession if you want to watch more of
these videos please subscribe to the
channel